how are you both doing
i'm great um how are you i'm doing
excellent
listen um i think that my sister has a
number of kids
and i think that they are going to love
this movie um i can see them watching it
again and again
and again and again and then again um so
i'll say congratulations uh for both of
you is it weird to be sitting
all day talking to people about the
movie are you still enjoying
like doing press um
yeah i would say so um you know it's
definitely
very fun to meet all these different
people from different outlets in
different parts of the country
you know we've done puerto rico italy
france ireland
it's just very crazy to meet all of
these amazing people
yeah um but we've met a lot of people
and i mean um we've
done a lot of press so far
um but i'm still enjoying it
i mean it's a lot it's a lot of work but
i still enjoy it i'm going to ask you
guys a question
that um has nothing to do with the movie
uh for each of you
what tv show would you love to guest
star on
okay i'm kind of i'm gonna be honest i'm
a little bit embarrassed about my answer
but that's gonna have to be julian the
phantoms i am
completely obsessed with that show and
that would be my ultimate dream because
i love every single person
on that show oh yeah yeah totally i
could
totally um see you playing one of
julie's friends or something
yeah that would be really cool um i
think mine
um this show is a little inappropriate
but it's called bob's burgers on
hulu um and i
kind of want to be that show it's like
one of my all-time favorite shows right
now
got it um jumping into why i get to talk
to you guys today
um you've both worked on other projects
before
but this was filled with having to do a
lot of visual effects
a lot of special effects what for each
of you what surprised you
about making a movie like this and all
the visual effects
i mean the fact that we had to react
to stuff that that either wasn't there
or was just like a little green thing
like it was very it was very surprising
that oh we have to pretend that that
pool
noodle is going to kill us oh yeah the
pool noodles
hilarious that's a lot to work with
um so there's literally a green guy
just sitting in the corner holding a
green pool
like alien
and um and we were like
robert you want us to be scared of a
green guy holding a green pool noodle
and it was hard but we eventually got it
yeah the cgi and special effects were
definitely
learning curve uh for both of you
i'm have before you had been cast in
this
had you seen spy kids and sharkboy and
lava girl
or was it something that you watched
after getting cast
um no i didn't i'm going to be very
honest well i think i watched spy kids 4
but that's only because it was on
netflix so of course i had watched it
um but i didn't and usually
you you know when you get an audition
they'll say watch this movie to like
take some notes because sometimes it'll
be the same casting directors or same
producers as the movie that you're
auditioning for
so when we had found out that he did spy
kids i was like oh i watched like the
number four of that movie so for
um the audition i watched i did not
watch spy kids but
when we were filming i did watch spy
kids and i
love spy kids now um
i remember um
i don't think we ever really watched spy
kids or shark boy lava girl before
i think the very first time we watched
shark wine lava girl we watched um
that night after i got the audition
because they didn't
tell us to watch out for lava girl
but i think it was kind of
implied and so um my mom was like
i think they want us to watch our blind
lava girl even though they didn't say it
very clearly
so um i was like
okay and mom had to do a lot of research
um until i finally understood who robert
rodriguez was
um and then um
we watched on lava girl and it was a
fairly good movie i liked it a lot
um i definitely have to ask you vivian
about riding uh the big shark in the
movie
and what was that actually like on set
and how did robert explain it to you
what it was all gonna be
oh wow that is
one of the questions i have been waiting
for okay so
um actually the stroke was about
a giant like this tall
block um that
was just like it's probably even taller
that was um on the green screen
and then it um
and then on top of it was a little green
rectangle like
this thick and this big on top
to represent the fin and then on the
back
there was little green stairs
so they had um
two green guys holding my hands like
this
and walking me up the stairs as slowly
as they could
um and then there were like
another green guy surrounding making
sure i didn't fall off even though it
was so thick there was no way i could
have fallen off that
um and then i sat on it and then i
um was supposed to hold on a little
above the green block
like this and then um robert
said um at one point
you won't even believe how real this is
going to look
and yeah got it
that that's a very good answer thank you
um i think that this is going to be a
very big hit for netflix
um and i'm not going to be surprised if
this you guys end up making a sequel
so i'm going to ask you what would you
love to see happen
in another movie
um i would like to see
um i would i would really like to see
my dad like have a little bit of romance
maybe like get a girlfriend or something
i don't know i think that that would be
really funny
um and then i'd also i i'd like maybe
for missy to get powers
um i think that that would be really
cool or maybe like
think she's getting powers and then
doesn't get powers i feel like that
would be really cool too
um and just to go on a bunch of other
adventures too
i think for me it would be to show a bit
more of my
lava girl side um and
i kind of have a question for robert if
guppy um has water and lava powers like
i'm hoping she gets lava powers in the
sea
if she has water and lava powers water
and lava makes land can guppy make lands
that's an excellent question um on that
note i have to rap
congratulations on the movie good luck
with all the other press
and i do hope you get to make a sequel
thank you so much